je vous rappelle la question orale
numéro 230 de Monsieur Gérard baayli à
monsieur le ministre de l'Agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la
forêt monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
rappeler ici la tenstion de monsieur le
ministre de l'Agriculture sur la
publication du rapport Seralini qui a
fait état de la dangerosité des OGM sur
des rats alimentés avec du maïs nk603
lui-même même traité avec de l'herbicide
rundolp cette information a été très
largement diffusée par les médias presse
écrite radio télévision on peut
comprendre que cette publication est
suscité de nombreuses interrogations des
craintes jugement négatifs vis-à-vis des
agriculteurs notamment ceux qui
utilisent ces produits d'autres experts
quelques jours après ayant ensuite réagi
de façon différente ces mêmes médias ont
quelques jours plus tard
relativisé la dangerosité révélé par les
expériences du professeur Seralini et la
crédibilité de cette étude mais je
dirais le mal était déjà fait ces
annonces sont toujours des conséquences
néfastes IR dramatiques pour les
producteurs toute filière confondu c'est
pourquoi je souhaiterais connaître les
obligations exigées ou qui pourraient
l'être avant publication de ces rapports
relatifs à notre santé une telle
publication susceptible de créer tant de
polémique ne devrait-elle pas être mieux
encadrée
comme de nombreux élus et comme tout
consommateur je souhaiteraiis que des
études importantes et sérieuses puissent
être faites au niveau européen sur
l'utilisation des OGM par des organismes
reconnus n'ayant aucun intérêt
commercial et ne prenant pas position
suivant les conclusions des travaux
aujourd'hui qui peut dire avec certitude
si oui ou non il y a danger pour notre
santé même s'ils sont interdits en
France nous savons malheureusement que
des produits importés consomm mais sur
notre territoire contiennent des OGM ce
qui est inquiétant les agriculteurs sont
les premiers à souhaiter ces travaux et
si la dangerosité était confirmée il
serait nécessaire indispensable que ces
techniques soient bannies et que
l'interdiction d'importer des produits
alimentaires ou servant à l'alimentation
animale le soit aussi soit total mais si
tel n'était pas le cas pourquoi
interdire en France les OGM plaçant les
agricultures français dans une situation
défavorable par rapport au pays
concurrents en matière de production
agricole chacun sait que la planète aura
besoin davantage de production
alimentaire ne dit-on pas j'ai la
confirmation encore ses jours que tous
les jours c'est 200000 tous les jours je
dis bien c'est 200000 humains de plus
chaque jour sur la planète dans les
années 50 ce sera 9 milliards d'hommes à
nourrir c'est pourquoi je pense qu'il
est impératif de connaître la dangeruse
des OGM pour la santé et si oui dans ce
cas préparer une agriculture qui aura
besoin de tous ces autres atouts pour
nourrir la planète je souhaiterai
connaître monsieur le ministre les
objectifs et les moyens que le
gouvernement envisage au niveau national
et je dirais presque au niveau surtout
européen pour obtenir des études
scientifiques sérieuses et fiables pour
les incidences de l'utilisation des
géomes sur notre santé et qui est vous
le savez tous notre bien le plus cher la
santé merci monsieursieur
ministre monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Sénateur monsieur bai j'ai bien
écouté votre question et en ce début
d'année c'est vrai que se souhaiter
bonne année on y ajoute souvent bonne
santé c'est ça l'essentiel donc je le
fais d'ailleurs et j'en profite ce matin
pour vous souhaiter bonne santé et bonne
année mais il y avait deux trois
éléments sur lesquels je voudrais
revenir le premier c'est que vous avez
noté à juste TR d'ailleurs que la
publication d'un certain nombre d'études
avec des impacts extrêmement puissants
dans l'opinion dès que ça concerne la
santé ne mériterait-elle pas un meilleur
encadrement question que vous avez posé
je vous rappellerai simplement une chose
c'est que cette étude serralini par
définition avait été caché aux yeux et
auessus de tout le monde pour être
justement sorti pour PIR pour pour avoir
l'impact dans l'opinion le plus
important possible donc on aurait pu
encadrer de toute façon personne n'était
au courant de la publication de cette
étude c'était l'enjeu même de cette
publication donc par rapport à la
question que vous posiez voyez même sur
ce cas précis on pouvait pas faire
grand-chose deuxième point vous avez
posé un certain nombre de questions qui
sont très justes sur la santé cette
étude révélait surtout à la fois une
question posée par un OGM et aussi une
question posée par l'herbicide qui était
que qui était résistant pour cet OGM
hein c'était c'est ça vous avez donné
son son nom commercial qu'on connaît
tous bien hein mais c'était aussi
l'objet de cette étude et une partie des
conséquences était lié à l'herbicide
lui-même la France a
interdit le recours l'utilisation du
maïs concerné et nous avons par contte
après avoir demandé des études à laness
et au HCB de confirmer la validité ou
non de cette fameuse étude sééalini mais
je l'avais dit dès le départ ça ne
change rien sur la nécessité que nous
avons de revoir les protocoles
d'autorisation à l'échelle européenne et
c'est pourquoi nous travaillons
aujourd'hui à la préparation justement
d'un certain nombre de textes pour
revisiter les règles qui s'appliquent
aujourd'hui sur cette question des OGM
débats qui sont récurrent dans beaucoup
d'endroits en Europe et qui nécessite
une clarification juridique à à
l'échelle européenne c'est la démarche
qui est la nôtre la France avait dit
d'ailleurs après cette étude qu'elle
saisiss qu'elle saisirait la commission
sur des propositions nouvelles on
s'appuie d'ailleurs sur les travaux qui
avaient été faits par le Parlement
européen fut il y a quelques années avec
Corine Lepage et moi-même sur lesqueles
nous allons pouvoir travailler pour
corriger et modifier les règles à la
fois d'autorisation et d'évaluation des
OGM pour répondre à la question que vous
avez posé il faut qu'on soit sûr hein
sur ces suj là scientifiquement de
préserver le premier bien qui est le
nôtre c'est-à-dire la santé merci
monsieur le sénateur merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur
bailli bien je voudrais d'abord remerci
monsieur le ministre d'avoir lui-même
répondu à mes questions posé je crois
qu'il concerne tout le monde puisque
c'est comme c'était dit la santé je suis
très sensible à sa réponse aussi puisque
je crois
que à peu près souhaite la même chose
que je le souhaitais moi-même et que
aujourd'hui avant public iation il faut
quand même qu'on arrive à faire plus
attention et puis aussi que la recherche
avance très rapidement au niveau
européen dans ce grand domaine là et
bien sûr vous comprendrez bien que comme
beaucoup d'autres je conteste aussi que
l'on puisse détruire des plantes quand
il y a des recherches juste qui vont
dans le sens de la recherche justement
qui profitent justement sur
l'utilisation des OGM je bannis un petit
peu ces destructions qui sont illogique
alors monsieur le ministre je crois que
il faut qu'on aille dans ce senslà votre
notre ministre euh de l'agroalimentaire
la semaine dernière où j'étais avec lui
à une réunion avanté et il se doit je la
remercie un petit peu les la les
produits français qui sont reconnus dans
dans nos produits agricoles dans les
plus sains euh je crois au niveau de la
planète qui a vanté également la
gastronomie française et a aussi euh la
demande de la gastronomie inscrite à
l'Unesco aussi va bien dans ce sens-là
donc ce serait dommage aussi et c'est
dommage je regrette que par des
publications comme ça on a on attache si
vous on met des tâches si vous voulez
dans ce que quand même quelque chose
d'important l'effort des agriculteurs
qui le font pour la qualité des produits
agricoles et c'est pourquoi Monsieur le
Ministre votre réponse me convient
complètement mais j'ose espérer que ce
soitz rapide dans les années qui
viennent et qu'on en parle encore pas
que dans 10 ans on n'est pas avancé
merci monsieur le ministre de votre